welcome to this video a new part of
endgame basics and theory yeah this is
night plus pawn against night very basic
endgame again we had bishop plus pawn
against Bishop earlier and now the same
with Knights in fact with Knights things
are as usual with this piece a little
trickier than with bishops bishops are
somewhat more predictable in the way
they don't leave their color complex and
they sometimes you can really operate
with things like okay if this diagonal
is this and that squares long okay it's
a draw what not if you have seen the
video on Bishop against Bishop plus
extra point you have seen this kind of
things with Knights it's tricky but this
is a tricky piece let's look at some key
positions to understand the whole affair
better in general without concrete
calculation it's very difficult in those
Knight end games but knowledge of some
basic positions of course does help
let's start with some very basic stuff
upon on the seventh rank if the plus
pawn the extra pawn here's on the
seventh rank and it is supported by the
King and it's not one of those side
pawns a and H pawn so one of those BCD
and so on in those cases it is a win for
the pawn on the seventh rank unless
there is an immediate draw and immediate
I mean like instant draw for example if
it is black to move in this position
that is on the board there is such an
instant draw that means of the move
Knight e5 a very important motif to know
and remember black is of course
threatening to just take the pawn and if
white promotes we win the Queen with the
fork
this is such an immediate draw however
if we go back to the neutral position
and switch the right to move to white
white is winning how exactly
let's look how it is done King e6
preventing this 95 idea
Czech tt6
oops should actually play the right move
not king c6 jumping all over the place
King f6 and now we have the knight
joining the party this is of course
essential without the night we cannot
win check King c7 King f5 we are keeping
the night away if black guy was to e7 we
see a very typical winning maneuver what
white needs to do now is of course to
deflect this Knight from the protection
of the d8 square what white basically
needs to do he needs to get the Knight
to d6 like this a ninety four ninety
eight ninety five dot f7 Knight p7 King
f6 96 and black is lost the pawn will
promote this is the typical procedure
you have to deflect this night that
control what's the promotion square in
the position here if black steps up with
the King to f5 it lasts a little bit
longer the whole thing but it is the
same winning procedure 93 King e6 night
before we are on the way
kingi 796 King f6 and now again we need
to go to this b7 square or C 4 square in
order to finally reach the desired
square on d6 let's actually Kinki 5 in
my my sample but it's not really
measuring that much it's still the same
idea which is absolutely essential and
we get the Queen yeah the Knight to d6
is the key deflecting the defending
Knight from the square this is the
typical winning procedure with the pawn
on the seventh rank there are various
versions of that we can look at
something yeah a slightly different
position with black to move this is one
of those cases again where there is an
immediate draw but something that you
can easily overlook if you don't know
the motif how is black now defending
this the way to draw is Knight ch-check
this is funny we just go down and now
it's it's really clear white can only go
to e8 this is the only way forward this
is just giving up the pawn immediately
so this and now the check King b7 and
the check again with an immediate draw
it's really it's really that simple
there is either an immediate draw with
tricks like that or something that we
have seen before the fork trick or white
will win with the pawn on the six rank
it's much more difficult to win
let's have a look at this typical
position again it is black to move and
defend here black has a way to draw and
this is King to age seven note that we
absolutely must stop the pawned here
when it is on f6 we cannot allow f7 if
black instead place something like this
there's f7 check King g7 97 and after
King move Knight f6 we already know the
story and this Knight move is deflecting
and then white will get the Queen their
only defense of try and in this case
it's a successful one is to let the
knight stay on g5 to God they have seven
square yeah how to progress him very
important is that if white tries Knight
f3 trying this typical deflection we can
take it because f7 95
Queen 96 is one of those funky 4 tricks
again this is the reason why this
endgame type is a little bit difficult
to assess on general terms you have to
look for concrete lines all the time
because it's full of those little tricks
but it's very important to know those
kind of flop tricks makes it much easier
to spot if you have it on the board
what else can watch rhyme Knight c4
maybe trying other ways to deflect the
slide
kingi 696 now important what should like
do you cannot move the night because of
Sam we have to move the King but where
do we go
King h5 is right here this is better and
much better than King age 7 after King
age 7 what has the move 94 and this now
is very tricky the problem is that in
this situation it's difficult it's
different to the knight coming to f3 as
here after this f7 95 there is this
check and now the problem is why should
the King go it's really only this square
otherwise we queen with check and here
the king is on exactly the square where
the knight should give the fork yeah so
it says it is a tightrope that black has
to walk but King h5 is drawing this is
looking at this it's not the reason that
we look at this is not like you should
learn this by heart or remember exactly
the same thing when you have it on the
board it's about looking at typical
motif so you get familiar to what
happens in this endgame and then you
really have to play it over the bonus
there will be specifics to every
position this is very typical for Knight
end games there really a pure
calculation grind if you want but it's
helpful so to know key motifs Knight e4
in this position again trying to deflect
but tonight f3 is holding the fort F 795
again being a draw and white really has
nothing else yes basically tried
everything there is
why'd can try the check I would at the
end there is still before it is some
basically a rule in the same game that
when both Kings are involved in the
fight when the pawn is on the six rank
it very often would be a draw if it is
further back the likelihood of a draw
increases tremendously if the pawn is on
the on the fifth rank for example all
this applies to plants that are not
flank pawns H pawn and apron it is
important to note that and very well
known that the knight is notoriously bad
as a defender against an A or an H pawn
the flank pawns let's have a look at one
example here we have such a typical
position yeah White has the apron tries
to win with these extra pawn and the
problem with those pawns is for the
night the night simply it's it's a
typical thing the knight on the rim is
dim this this old rule the night simply
has less it controls less squares on the
side of the board and there's simply a
somewhat clumsy piece if it's not near
the center in this concrete case white
actually can win let's have a look what
what happens 95 is the first move and
again at the end as a matter of
deflecting of course the defender King
to before
97 king fi ya black can cannot really do
anything else
98 you know and here this is the key
idea check King v6 back and then we can
try to to move the pawn you know if
black black he is basically and then
some sort of some sort of Zeus one he
played on this is a study actually by
beretta the check here as the Chavis
defense 27 shake king c6
yeah and now the King has to move King a
for a king to be sick so we have gained
this b6 square and now the next step is
to try to dislodge this night from b5
here we go
black has to resort to this typical frog
tricks a 7 and the check so a 7 is not
the way to go we have to do this right
back to c8 and we have reached this
position now the promotion is threatened
and like it really has no defense
against this yeah it's just a case where
the knight is such a clumsy piece to
defend against upon he has no chance to
get the sacrifice in as mentioned it is
a matter of concrete concrete
calculation all the time if we go back
to the initial position jump all the way
back here it was 95 what happens if it's
black stools that just to just to show
what happens there if if black is moving
first we have the suits 1 even earlier
there is no check this is protected so
he has to move
King King to be forum king b6 and now we
are close to this dislodging maneuver
again King c4 right here
96 98 it is 4 it is tricky this endgame
here and again
yeah that's it's really it's really neat
and we will promote yeah something like
that shows why the knight is sometimes a
clumsy piece yeah so not Knight xe7 but
96 96 in this position we already know
so the flank pawn normally gives good
winning chance because the night is so
I'm just so problematic as a defender
it's awesome in all those cases we had
both Kings near them near the pole this
is also an important factor if the
defending King of course is far away
from the pawn the winning chances
increase considerably let's have a look
at a position from a practical game yeah
this is a position from an actual game
all the former positions were with
studies this is from a game Kasparov
playing white against Michael Adams
Daenerys 1999 it turns out that here
the white king being centralized the
black King being far away from the
action means that in fact white is
winning here he only has a real winning
news though this is king deform later
Kasparov you just want to look at some
typical things it's a it's enough to
know that this is a pretty logical thing
but it's enough to know that the the
more the far away the King is
the the defending king is the better the
winning Joneses all night a six lost
Adams choice of a defense seems that
night b3 was a little bit tougher of
course nowadays we can check all this
with table bases and check the perfect
play if you are interested um just
search form for table bases online and
put this position on the board you can
try to win this against perfect defense
if you if you like it's not so easy just
want to show them main continuation what
was actually played by by Adams tonight
a6 Kasparov played King g5g g six night
to deform King f6 King V six note that
there is a sort of night domination now
controlled controlled controlled
controlled the Black Knight is not able
to escape from this so easily king f7
was played and now 926 yeah into this
position Adams already resigned the
reason is that he cannot really avoid
the trade of the night after which the
pawn will promote it's quite nice
actually
what should like do now let's say um
Knight p8 we go here dominating the
knight and threatening King here my
difficulty me a ball this is very simple
we just trade the night so the position
here on the edge of the board really
really got him we can maybe briefly
check the other defense if we
if we go back to the initial position
just a moment yeah this is the initial
position records for played King before
this seems to be a little bit tougher we
can briefly look at it
King say 495 check before 96 King c5
Knight back and a for ya tonight against
the flank pawn hmm
it always is tricky changes 694 you're
taking away this square won't be three
and intending to advance him attacking
the knight King f6 king b5 the night
drops back
Knight b3 yeah we want to go here to
make the a pawn run finally King e5 King
2b 686 into c4 yeah in an actual game
you really have to check all those
possibilities it's very difficult to
play 9 c4
yeah and here is one of those funny
situations where the the problems of the
night are highlighted quite clearly here
white is some is winning with the very
funny move 92 the pawn is very far away
from promoting but you can actually do
that because after Knight takes e5 Black
has no way to stop it
yeah this is the the problem with this
flank pawn against the night white now
will promote okay you can try all kinds
of things but it is really not possible
to stop them stop the pawn yeah it will
promote this is some quite typical
scenario you can very often use those
deflection
ideas even at a stage where the point
isn't that far advanced simply due to
the fact that it is the flank pawn that
is notoriously difficult for the knight
to stop there is also this very typical
idea that that should be noted if we put
on a new position yeah something that
definitely should be known as this kind
of situation the knight in a let's say
fianchetto position on b7 when white to
move place a six he will win because
black has no way to stop the pawn it's a
very typical thing that happens very
often even if the king is nearby I mean
we can easily alter the position like
that even then there is a big problem a
six King c7 a seven and it promotes
quite funny yeah so this is a another
case where the knight is especially
problematic as a defender against the
flank pawn um as an additional thing for
this video it can be mentioned that if
you have two extra points with no
opponent on the other side you should
actually win almost all of the time
unless there is a very concrete reason
why it why it shouldn't happen however
you always need to be careful that it is
quite clear because one lights are very
very tricky we can look at one example
just to see how it it is unfolding yeah
this is an example from a practical game
why these two pawns up so it looks like
he should win but they are very far back
so not an easy technical task let's just
see how it and fold it in this game
before
9f for the players by the way I blog
going of each and maximovich it was
slave Ian championship in the 90s night
at 4:00 night b2 to cover the square and
we will play a for short
shortly afterwards 92-93 Chuck again a
check yeah yeah
the night is is always a tricky defender
yeah but now we managed to break through
a with the king
96 night f1 that's important so that we
actually get access to the central
square and two pawns are really really
hard to stop this is this is running and
the a pawn is something that we have in
reserve check King to d5 King b6 + f5
King c7
again we have improving the night
position first back here yeah and now it
looks like a fairly trivial win the pawn
will promote two pawns are normally a
little bit too much simply because it's
simple sacrifice against the opponent's
will not work for the 9s a is they a
pawn in reserve so with two points
you're you're winning almost all of the
time unless you yeah well if you blunder
one of them it's not a good idea
but with them with good calculation not
giving away one of the points it should
be a winner all the time the big advice
really for Knight end games is even
those very simple ones is that it is a
very concrete type of endgame where you
should try to calculate as precisely as
possible there are very little things to
know remember motives whatever what we
have seen a couple those kind of folks
that get the Queen back once it has
promoted and those kind of deflecting
ideas however everything there is quite
specific to the position at hand it is
some not so easy to get to some handful
of rules or some two or three key
positions like it sometimes is in rook
end games where you just know okay I'll
keep the rook on the six rank and I'll
draw it's not that simple or
straightforward in a 9/10 game yeah I
hope you enjoyed this coverage of this
base again game maybe it will say if you
have a point here and down or maybe win
you some some games if you know those
those little tricks even draw on
position can be one if you're huntin
asia's okay I hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching